okay
hi so this is how you guys doing hi
we're doing great
[Music]
this was the very first episode of the
joe rogan experience all the way back in
2009.
at the time only around a hundred people
were watching live nobody's watching
this i think
we have 10 people in here yeah this is
113 already wow okay
this is like a 113 people's like a show
at a comedy club now i feel pressure a
little over 10 years later
this tiny little podcast full of
swearing politically incorrect jokes i
wouldn't fly today
and anything and everything joe rogan
was interested in would not only become
the biggest podcast in the world
but the most valuable at 100 million
dollars after signing with spotify
recently
but that's not the crazy part the crazy
part is that before the podcast was even
a thing and still to this day
joe rogan has had one of the most
diverse careers any major influencers
have ever had
a career spanning martial arts as a
taekwondo champion tv with news radio
and fear factor
commentating for the ufc to stand up
comedy and of course the joe rogan
experience
so let's take a look at the meteoric and
very diverse career of who's gonna be
one of the most influential figures of
our time
joe rogan okay there is no competition
here
joe's the guy when it comes down to
podcasts jamie
jamie pull it up just pull it up jamie
curious about you because you're such a
strange character
in the most interesting of ways i am a
[ __ ] i'm doing intermittent fasting
only eating elk
while in this stomach we went to see joe
rogan and he hates gays
and cats i am currently blogging about
it
joe rogan has done nearly 700 episodes
with actors
so if you love movies like me and
probably joe you've probably ran into a
problem like this before
you search for a movie you want to watch
but netflix doesn't have it
well netflix probably does have the
movie you want but it's just restricted
based on where you live
so you're paying full price for netflix
but you're only getting a slither of all
the content they have
that is where today's video sponsor
comes in expressvpn
with expressvpn i can find what
locations the movies i want to watch are
restricted to
then i change my location with a simple
click in the app and boom
there it is i can now access the entire
netflix library no matter where i'm at
so if you want to access all the content
on your streaming platforms while
protecting yourself online with the best
rated vpn in the game for a very
reasonable price
pause the video right now and find out
how you can get three months free by
clicking the link in the description box
below
expressvpn.comtran and then come back to
this video because we're going to break
down joe rogan
that's expressvpn.com jake tran with the
link below
[Music]
joseph james rogan didn't have the worst
childhood ever but it also wasn't that
great according to him
he moved around a lot so he never had
any early childhood friends
he was always the new kid and since he
wasn't all that big of a kid
he got picked on born in new jersey into
a tumultuous household where his parents
were fighting all the time
once his mom divorced his dad and they
escaped new jersey at age seven
joe described it as a relief well it was
tumultuous time period for me my parents
were always fighting and it just wasn't
a good time so when we escaped new
jersey it was a relief
from age seven and on joe would never
talk to his biological dad again to this
day
he's still alive and his name's joe
rogan which is even crazier
he was nice to me he just wasn't very
nice to my mother
so they had a very bad relationship from
there his mom married his stepdad and
they moved to san francisco this was at
the height of the vietnam war
so joe went from having a cop as a dad
in new jersey to having a hippie as a
dad in hippie central
after moving to florida at around age 11
joe and his family moved to boston at
age 13 where he would spend the next 11
years of his life
boston is where joe really grew up
during his developmental years
and it would be where the joe rogan we
know today really takes form
growing up in a troubled household joe
rogan developed an extremely obsessive
personality
he was very interested in what he was
interested in and very uninterested in
people telling him what to do
this is something that would play a
major role in his future success
at the same time he always felt like a
loser he was always afraid of the
bullies that picked on him but that
would all soon change at around age 14
to 15.
one day he was leaving a red sox game in
boston but the line for the train was
too long
so him and his friend decided to check
out the j hung kim taekwondo institute
and so i walked up to the top of the
stairs and i i heard this
crazy sound of this what it turned out
to be this man
kicking this bag and slamming his heel
into this bag and having the chain
snap and and rattle i couldn't believe a
person could do that i'd never seen
anybody kick something so hard in real
life anybody that had
such an incredible martial arts skill
like this guy did john lee
after that he was there the next day i
mean here i am
devoting most of my time to trying to
get really good at knocking people
unconscious
and that's what i was those that's what
i was trying to do i was trying to
separate people from their consciousness
that was i was
doing my best every day to get good at
that this was the first thing in joe's
life where he didn't feel like a loser
joe's obsessiveness was 100 directed at
training and fighting
what do you think it is about you that
enables you to zero in on something like
that to the exclusion of everything else
i don't know i mean i think some of it
has to be attributed to the unhappiness
of my childhood
and that when i would find something
that i did get some joy out of
i would just concentrate all in on that
as any martial artist will tell you
there's something truly liberating about
being capable of violence
and knowing that you can probably handle
yourself if poop went down in most
situations
in aligning yourself with the more
violent roots of our nature
you look at the world differently you
carry yourself differently and that's
exactly what happened to joe
he went from being the unconfident kid
that avoided conflict to a taekwondo
fighter
i became someone who i would be afraid
of you know
i became the opposite of what i was
needless to say bullying was never a
problem anymore
he very quickly got the keys to the
studio and was soon teaching classes in
exchange for free training
within two years he earns black belt won
the state championships at 18 and for
the next three years straight
started competing all over the country
and won the us open championship at 19
as a lightweight then as a middleweight
and then as a heavyweight which earned
him the grand championship
there's a lot of violence in me for sure
i don't know if it's genetic or learned
or
it's because during my formative years
from the time i was
15 until i was 22 all i did was fight
that was all i did keep in mind that
back then taekwondo was not the foot
fencing point scoring bs that it is
today
back then it was pretty brutal with very
soft protective gear so these were some
hardcore accomplishments
i have a scarily similar story with
taekwondo's joe so i do mostly know what
i'm talking about here
and martial arts will remain the center
of his life from age 14 to 15 to 21 to
22
until he made the transition into comedy
at age 19
joe started pondering the idea of
fighting professionally but he also
started worrying about brain damage
injuries were starting to pile up he
could see the cognitive function of
other athletes he was around start to go
down
and he knew that this life couldn't last
forever on top of that unless you're in
something like the ufc
there is not that much money in fighting
the final nail in the coffin was when
joe nearly killed the guy in the ring
one time in a martial arts fight i
knocked this guy out he never got up
and i i started thinking that could be
me i went back to talk to my instructor
i said yeah i go
it was um it was really scary because he
never got up
i mean he was i thought he was dead and
he goes
sometimes they die geez they just walked
away
that doubt stuck with me um for the next
couple of years
it was probably the first seed of uh my
new future was
me hurting that guy and thinking about
what that was gonna be like
if that happened to me
your point of view is terrible yeah so i
make a living
jonah's martial arts friends were always
in an intense environment
whether it was in training or
competitions they were always stressed
and nervous
so the beginning of joe's comedy career
started out with him just making jokes
to lighten the mood
the idea of being a comedian never
crossed his mind until his friends
encouraged him to try it out
at first joe wasn't convinced the same
dark politically incorrect humor he has
today was the same humor he had back
then
but probably even worse even though he
didn't see himself as a loser
anymore he definitely thought he was
some weird outlier in society
that my friends only think i'm funny
because i'm their friend society would
never like my dark sense of humor
that was until his friend convinced him
to go to an open mic night and the thing
about open mic nights is that people are
pretty terrible
so it encourages you to try mix that
with the motivation to find a way out of
fighting
and joe found himself doing open mic
nights and once he realized that hey
there's a small chance that i could make
a living out of this he directed all
that same obsession that turned him into
a taekwondo champion
into stand-up comedy i mean my first set
that i ever did i had a bunch of my
friends come down and watch me i wasn't
good
the first time i ever got on stage but i
got a couple of little chuckles and
laughs
and then i realized this might be
possible and after three years of
falling on his face
traveling all over the place for open
mic nights all with the goal of one day
being able to pay his bills by telling
jokes
he caught his break i met my manager my
manager who's my manager to this day
he basically picked me up when i was an
open mic medium i mean i was i was
getting a few paid gigs here and there
but i was really an amateur
he was looking for new talent he came up
from new york he was a
like you know really well respected and
well recognized
manager still is he moved to new york
doing more and more stand-ups really
hone in this new skill and by 25 to 26
years old he
achieved his dreams of being able to pay
his bills with comedy
joe eventually found himself on mtv's
half hour comedy hour and it went really
well
girlfriend came in the room just like
joe if you had to choose between madonna
and me
who would you pick
tons of offers came in to be on tv and
within one year
joe found himself in la for the next
phase of his career
[Music]
the first sitcom show was called
hardball but it got cancelled
stuck in la because of his lease joe
decided to stay to see what came up
and he ended up starring on a hit sitcom
called newsradio
have you seen any good movies lately uh
me i i don't go to movies i don't like
movies
most movies suck that show went on for
five seasons while he was doing stand up
on the side
and once the show ended joe was sick of
working with actors
so nbc pitched the idea of him hosting a
new show without actors called fear
factor
it was a preposterous show like from the
jump and i always thought it was going
to be canceled
and it was a giant hit it was a giant
huge show
and be like like immediately it was a
hit i was like this is so stupid the
show is so stupid
and as it turns out a guy that's coach
athletes makes jokes for a living and
has been on tv
made for the perfect host of fear factor
here we go put your daughter in your
head right now
i want you to do this for your daughter
it was around this time in 1997 that joe
started commentating for the ufc
after dana white asked them to i'm back
here right now backstage i'll be
interviewing the fighters as they come
out of the octagon we're live with
victor congratulations victor
unbelievable victory either way folks
it's gonna be a barn burner
he started out doing 12 events for free
and 18 years later he's still going
strong and getting paid very handsomely
for it
fear factor turned out to be a cash cow
for joe with him hosting 148 episodes
from 2001
to 2006. even though he wasn't as
passionate about it like he was for
stand-up he didn't have to worry about
money anymore
and after fear factor ended joe started
focusing on his own stuff
i made a ton of money and it alleviated
financial pressure
i didn't love being there for fear
factor but it was a great job and i knew
it was a great job and i knew
i was really lucky to have it so it was
great in that respect but when it was
over
i'd kind of decided i was done with
television this was when his comedy
career really reached a new level
around a year later his first comedy
special came out joe rogan live
and his cd shiny happy god in 2009 he
did a comedy special and spike tv
special called talking monkeys in space
and he would continue to release new
specials around every two years
and just as his comedy career started
taking off after fear factor
so did his new side project that would
go down in history as perhaps his
greatest contribution to the world
[Music]
hello world the first episode of the joe
rogan experience aired on december 2009
like many things joe did it started out
just for fun video and sound are okay
but the snowflakes are annoying
does everybody feel like the snowflakes
are annoying is just one dude that's
kind of
you know anal and remember podcasts are
just starting to get mainstream right
now
way back in 2009 the idea of a
three-hour long podcast of people just
talking was just as fringe as it gets
what started out as joe just bantering
with comedian friends eventually became
a weekly thing
then they got it on itunes it took years
before it made any money and eventually
it evolved into what it is today
where joe basically talks to anyone he
finds interesting but the podcast sort
of
um took on a life of its own which
brings us to today a little over 10
years later
jre now spans across the globe with over
1500 episodes
it looks to me like the podcast youtube
world
has even more impact in places where the
press is
not very reliable everybody knew about
our interviews and our podcasts and so
i was stopped in slovenia constantly
which is that was a real shock too
the jre clips channel was started back
in 2017 and today the podcast has some
truly incomprehensible numbers
the last time we talked i think you were
getting something approximately 100
million downloads a month on your
podcast
what are your figures if you didn't if
you don't mind why don't you double that
double that jesus christ i try to pay as
little attention to the numbers as
possible
and just concentrate on doing the show i
think if i pay attention to it too much
i might lose my mind
back in the cable tv days the
gatekeepers just assumed that people
weren't smart enough to want to listen
to deep conversations for a few hours
they were limited by airtime ads etc
start recording
bam it's happening right now
so not only did joe stumble across this
incredible unmet need for long-form
conversations at the very beginning of
its inception
not only is he a genuinely curious
person that is able to really listen to
his guests
joe also did what he does best he leans
into what makes him weird
joe has always been himself since
episode one you know and i've been
guilty of it myself you know like
i used to really be into ufos and all
kinds of stuff like that until i kind of
realized
like what i'm into is the unknown i have
a love-hate relationship with
conspiracies i love some of them some of
them are fascinating some of them like
okay what the [ __ ] happened there
and then some of them like i can't do
this anymore
joe lennon the 100 million dollar
spotify deal back in may 2020
and moved to austin texas shortly after
he said it was because he wanted a place
with more freedom in general which is
true
i just want to go somewhere in the
center of the country
somewhere it's easier to travel to both
places and somewhere we have a little
bit more freedom
but let's be honest california taxes on
that 100 million dollars was probably
pretty high on the list
after the deal joe said he kind of feels
like one of them now
i'm not a regular person anymore now i'm
like some
famous rich guy so you go from being a
regular person to a famous rich guy
that's out of touch
so what's next for joe rogan right now
he's married has three daughters
and he says he loves what he's doing and
just aims to continue improving the
podcast
his stand-up comedy and his other
projects like his fitness and supplement
company on it
i'd like to continue doing what i'm
doing i'm very happy that people enjoy
the show
i'm very very happy that it's affecting
people in a positive way
i mean i'm very very happy with my my
career
and family life i couldn't be happier so
i just like to keep doing what i'm doing
i don't have any crazy aspirations
other than continuing to get better at
everything that i try to work at
so what can we take away from joe well a
lot
but i want to offer something that
you're probably not going to hear from
many other places
the key to genius to being a genius to
doing something great like joe
is the ability to connect different
disciplines together
think about it today's world pounds us
with the idea of how a jack of all
trades is a master of none
and yet joe rogan doesn't specialize in
just one thing
no he's got experience in a bunch of
different disciplines
martial arts comedy long firm
conversations hunting psychedelics and
combines all of this
into his untouchable empire in fact if
you look at all the great innovators
throughout history
you'll see the same thing leonardo da
vinci saw beauty in both art and
engineering and his ability to combine
them was what made him a genius
benjamin franklin became the da vinci of
his era with no formal education
and became one of america's best
scientists innovators diplomats writers
and business strategists
steve jobs combined liberal arts and
technology and einstein would pull out
his violin and play mozart
which helped him reconnect with the
harmonies of the cosmos
so instead of a jack of all trades as a
master of none i propose another idea
be a jack of all trades and a master
of one mix in what the average person
would call an unhealthy amount of
obsession
curiosity and a desire to keep improving
and who knows
maybe one day you'll create something as
big as the joe rogan empire as well
anything if you work at anything you're
trying to improve
you know there's always room there's
always room for improvement and
everything yep and there's
all the personality and your work and
everything
and that's what i strive for i strive
for improvement
guys these video essays especially many
documentaries like this one take a lot
of work to make
so if you enjoyed it and you want to
support this channel financially so we
can continue making videos like this
all i ask is that you click the link
below and try out our sponsor expressvpn
they are consistently ranked the number
one leader in online privacy and
security by a ton of different
publications
including cnet the verge wired tech
radar and many more
think about all the valuable stuff you
access online your bank account your
google account all the inappropriate
online messages you sent that you hope
no one ever gets a hold of
if expressvpn just stops one attacker
from getting access to all your valuable
private information
it will probably pay for itself 10 times
over maybe more depending on those
messages in browsing history
combine that with the cool netflix trick
we talked about earlier and you can see
that having a vpn really is a
requirement these days
especially as more and more of our lives
have moved online so pause the video
right now and find out how you can get
three months free by clicking the link
in the description box below
expressvpn jaketran
it has been a long time since we've done
a why on winning video so if you want
more let me know who i should do next in
the comments below
and if you are still watching this right
now and you're still not subscribed
come on man so hit that red subscribe
button below and if you want emo
notifications for when new videos come
out
that way you don't have to rely on the
very unreliable notification bell you
can join the inbox notification squad
with the link below
and no i'm not going to sell your data
if you want behind the scenes stuff day
in the life kind of stuff you can follow
me on instagram
jaketrend.io we have a ton of fun over
there and that is going to wrap it up so
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been chick stay
dangerous out there like joe rogan and
i'll see you guys in the next one
foreign